SIERRA: Hey everyone! Heads up that this is
the last episode of our second season. We’re
taking a break to work on new episodes for
Season 3 and will be returning in the fall.
So stay tuned, stay safe,
and thanks for listening!
In times of war, art and culture may seem
relatively unimportant. And this means they
usually get overlooked - until it’s too late.
But throughout history, conflict has led to the
looting and destruction of art and heritage sites.
And in many cases, looted objects are used to fund
ongoing bloodshed. The repercussions can continue
for decades after the conflict itself has ended.
My name is Gabrielle Sierra, and
this is Why It Matters. Today, how
does art become a casualty, and a weapon, of war?
SIERRA: So can you tell me what cultural
heritage is and why it's important?
AL-AZM: Well, cultural heritage is essentially
what represents the shared common history that
a group of people might have. And it can be
something very specific, as pertaining to a
single group of people, a country, a region, or
it could be a worldwide issue. My name is Amr
Al-Azm. I'm a professor of Middle East history and
anthropology at Shawnee State University in Ohio.
Cultural artifacts are part of your heritage.
So if we're thinking of past cultural heritage,
you're thinking of the remains left
by ancient peoples, civilizations,
etc. And these can be archaeological sites,
archaeological monuments, and also artifacts left
behind, and an artifact can be something as simple
as a stone tool, a sickle, a mortar and pestle
that's used to produce food to something extremely
elaborate and intricate and very, very beautiful.
SIERRA: So how big of a problem is the looting of
art and cultural heritage, of cultural artifacts.
AL-AZM: Looting is a huge problem. But
it's also important to point out right
away that it's not a new problem. It's a
problem as old as human history itself.
DAVIS: As long as we have had tombs, we've
had tomb raiders. As long as there have been
civilizations, you know, there's been an
army waiting on the next hill to come in
and plunder them. We've seen throughout history
that culture has always been a weapon of war.
Hi, I'm Tess Davis, and I'm executive director
of the Antiquities Coalition, a not-for-profit
organization in Washington. It starts in places
like war-torn Cambodia, war-torn Cyprus, war-torn
Iraq or Yemen or Libya, the list goes on and
on. And this is funding conflict, it is funding
terrorism, and it's certainly funding crime
around the world which is why everyone should
care about it, regardless of whether they're
interested in culture or the arts or preservation.
One problem that everyone has faced who's
working in this area, is that so many view this
as a white-collar, victimless crime, and that's if
they view it as a crime at all. But that's not the
case. It might end up a white collar crime at the
end, but it doesn't start that way. And these are
cultural objects. And they really run the gamut
from those that are looted from archaeological
sites or stolen from museums or other collections
in war zones and then trafficked by armed groups
either to finance the hostilities, or sometimes
by individuals to exploit them for personal gain.
From the perspective of an archaeologist, of a
historian, you know, when an artifact is removed
from its context, we lose priceless history that
we're never going to get back again. Many of these
are sacred objects that were never meant to be
bought and sold. They are pieces that were, you
know, hacked off of a Hindu temple or a Buddhist
shrine. They're not meant to be commodities. And
many of these sacred places, they're still sacred
places. And when an object is taken from them,
it's as if it's destroyed, because you know,
that villager in that village they're never
going to see it again. And, you know, it
matters a great deal to these communities.
SIERRA: When an artifact is improperly
removed from its resting place,
the damage can’t be undone. The losses are
devastating. So what’s driving the looting?
Al-AZM: You know, areas like the Middle East
are extremely rich in cultural heritage; every
Syrian lives either on top of an archaeological
site, right next door to an archaeological site,
or within a stone's throw of an archaeological
site. Now you put stress, you put a conflict,
you put a situation where people lose their
livelihoods, and they will turn to looting. And
so, much in fact of the looting that we see today
in conflict countries like Syria, like Libya,
like Yemen, is very much associated with what we
refer to as subsistence looting. People will turn
to loot in order to survive to make ends meet to
try and find an additional source of income. And,
certainly there is a long established history
as well of criminal elements, mafias, gangs, or
corrupt officials in many of these countries, you
know. So, you find that added factor in, making
looting lucrative but also highly destructive
as we see when it's completely uncontrolled.
SIERRA: War leads to lost livelihoods, and
pushes people to steal and sell items to
get by. But throughout history, looting has
also happened on a much larger scale. Not
just the plundering of archaeological sites -
but the outright theft of art from individuals.
One of the most infamous cases was perpetrated by
the Nazis - who plundered hundreds of thousands
of paintings, sculptures, books and religious
objects during World War II - as much as 20
percent of all the art in Europe. The
looting was carried out with ruthless
organizational efficiency, and many of the
objects are still being tracked down today.
In response to this theft, a group was formed
to save and document art during the war. You
may have heard of these guys, called the
Monuments Men, because of a Hollywood flick.
Monuments Men: “You can wipe out a generation of
people, you can burn their homes to the ground
and somehow they’ll still come back. But if you
destroy their achievements and their history,
then it’s like they never existed.”
SIERRA: The theft also led to the creation
of the 1954 Hague Convention protecting
cultural property. It established the
first rules safeguarding locations
and items of cultural importance
in the event of armed conflict.
This same convention made it a war crime
to intentionally target cultural property.
And yet, while these international frameworks are
essential - looting continues to happen every day,
and art and artifacts remain backburner issues
when the world turns its attention to conflict.
DAVIS: I frequently get asked, with regards
to say, a place like Iraq or Yemen today,
that now is facing COVID on top of civil war
and other epidemics, disaster after disaster.
Is it disrespectful to even work on this issue
when they're dealing with so many other problems?
And what they've told us is that’s when it matters
more than ever, we want to have this culture to
pass on to our children. When everything else is
threatened most, that's when this matters most.
SIERRA: For years now Tess has
focused her attention on Cambodia,
where she has worked with the Royal Government
to preserve and protect cultural artifacts.
DAVIS: The case of Cambodia, is very important
because what we're seeing today in Iraq and Syria
and Yemen, it happened before. And as we see it,
you know, a generation ago the global hotspot,
it wasn't Mesopotamia, it wasn’t Iraq and Syria,
it was Indochina, Vietnam, Laos, and Cambodia,
and in Cambodia, which is celebrated now for its
Temple of Angkor Wat, which frequently shows up
on the must-visit list you'll see from Travelocity
and places like that. In 1970, war erupted between
the government and the Khmer Rouge, and that
led to decades of civil war, of genocide,
of foreign occupation that ended really only with
the 1998 death of Pol Pot. And by the time this
was all over, a quarter of the population’s lives
had been lost to starvation, to disease, and to
outright murder. And like we're seeing today in
the Middle East, in North Africa, the Civil War,
it triggered an organized industrial trade in
antiquities. And the purpose of that was to
bankroll further violence and the conflict, it was
intimately connected. And this, this trafficking
went hand in hand, as we're also seeing today
in the Middle East, in North Africa, with the
deliberate and systematic destruction of targeted
groups and their heritage. You know, there's this
real connection between plunder and destruction,
which, you know, it blurs the scene a little bit,
but they go hand in hand, whether you're talking
about World War Two, whether you're talking about
the Cambodian Civil War, and whether you're
talking about, you know, ISIS in Iraq today.
PBS News Hour: When it comes to the
battle against the Islamic State,
much of the world's attention is focused, of
course, on the murders and the mayhem it has
wrought. But there have also been a series of
attacks on antiquities and cultural heritage.
CBS News: Several options here but
I think use, “This video appears
to show … and shatter the priceless relics.
CNN: More than three thousand years
of history, obliterated in seconds.
SIERRA: What roles do terrorist
organizations play in this process?
AL-AZM: ISIS as a good example of how this sort of
happens. The looting had already started in Syria
from as early as 2012 and so when ISIS eventually
emerges at the end of 2013, and into 2014,
it emerges onto an already existing situation
as far as looting is concerned. They first and
foremost take over the trade and institutionalize
it. They start off by first saying to people,
okay, you can continue looting but you have
to pay a 20% tax on anything that you sell.
They also started to issue looting licenses
to individuals. So we would go to the local
ISIS Emir who controls an area and you say, hey,
look, I want to loot the site, and the Emir will
give you a permit. And then you go and start
digging. But very soon, I think ISIS realizes
that this is a very profitable venture, and they
start to get increasingly involved themselves;
they start to hire their own crews, they
start to bring in heavy digging equipment. And
they start to also host these auctions and one of
the biggest and most important was in Raqqa, and
they set up an entire department as part of the
Office of Mineral Wealth and Resources. So they
institutionalized the looting of cultural heritage
because it was financially profitable for them.
SIERRA: But ISIS didn’t only see these
treasures as a source of income. They
also used archeological sites for other
purposes, turning them into shields during
conflict and ultimately as a means of
showcasing their power to the world.
AL-AZM: They saw cultural heritage as a
resource on many different levels. So,
for example, when the International Coalition
started to do airstrikes on ISIS, after 2015,
ISIS started to use important cultural
heritage sites in Syria and Iraq,
to put their ammunition dumps, they use them
as training camps for their, you know, goods.
I have seen pictures collected by some of
our activists who worked with us in Syria
by siting oil refineries, on archaeological
sites. And of course, the most, you know,
horrific form of exploitation of cultural
heritage, we see from late 2015 onwards,
and this is demonstrated by what I refer [to] as
a cultural atrocities. This is when ISIS started
to go into museums and smashing the contents of
these museums or going into major archaeological
sites and smashing the contents and culminating
in the now iconic image of the Temple of Bel in
Palmyra being blown up and all of the these are
pre-prepared, they're videoed, and there's usually
some sort of narrative that goes with them.
And they are often released to coincide with
specific moments that they decide. So they’re
using these actions, these cultural atrocities
as a form of propaganda. And demonstrating
to its own narrow group of followers, look,
we are powerful. And so you can see that cultural
heritage here is being exploited on many levels.
DAVIS: ISIS, whatever you may say about them they
were very good businessmen. You know, it went from
a ragtag group of fighters to the richest terror
organization in history, and how did they do that?
They did it through criminal enterprises, through
a mix of extortion, you know, ransom and robbery
and looting, and unfortunately, found a willing
market. Something else that has changed with this
conflict in comparison with those past I mean,
even if you're looking at the Iraq invasion in
2003, someone on the Iraqi border can now through
Facebook, through WhatsApp, sell directly to a
buyer in rural Indiana and you know, FedEx a piece
there, and have it there in a matter of days where
it used to involve this quite complicated system
of dealers and middleman and transport. You know,
that too, has changed completely, and so criminals
have been taking advantage of this technology. And
I think law enforcement themselves would say
that they're having a hard time keeping up.
AL-AZM: I mean, social media has transformed the
landscape here. And we see an explosion from 2013
onwards, as Facebook becomes more popular in the
Middle East region, and particularly in areas like
Syria, Iraq, Libya, Yemen, all these conflict
zones as well, it becomes the great equalizer
because suddenly, you could be just an average
person with zero or no connections, you get
on Facebook, you find you just post your your
wares online and millions of people can see it.
SIERRA: Social media gives everyone a voice, but
that connectivity usually has a dark side too. In
the case of looted art, social platforms are often
the first step in the laundering process that
allows pieces to make their way to the mainstream
art market. More on this after the break.
SIERRA: How does a looted object eventually
show up for sale on a legal art market?
DAVIS: I should say one of the many difficulties
of fighting this illicit trade is that unlike
drugs, unlike guns, cultural objects aren't
automatically illicit. You can't tell by looking
at something if it's illegal or not. It depends
on the history, and, in fact, for this reason, if
you look at the research, the scholarship that's
being done on this increasingly criminologists
are comparing it more to laundering. That these
things aren't just being trafficked, they're being
laundered onto the legitimate market. The art
market is the largest unregulated legal market
in the world. You can buy a car for hundreds or
thousands of dollars and you get a VIN number,
you get an ownership history, you get all of
these things, but you buy a $500 million painting
and you don't know the name of the person who's
selling it. In how many industries does that
happen? And I think it's been able to continue
like that, again, because of this mistaken concept
that art crime is a white collar, victimless
crime, and certainly there's aspects of that,
but again, there's very serious reasons for
governments to care about this. And one case
with which I was very honored to work was an
antiquity from Cambodia, a masterpiece, that was
looted in the chaos leading up to the Killing
Fields. It was broken into pieces, smuggled
across the border to Thailand by insurgents,
most likely the Khmer Rouge, and then it was
slowly laundered onto the European art market,
given a false history and then, you know, shows
up for sale on the cover of a catalog for one of
the most prominent auction houses in the world.
SIERRA: Wow.
DAVIS: Yeah, missing its feet
which remain chopped off at the
ankles behind at the site. Luckily,
that piece has been returned home,
but most are not. Most that disappear into
the black market sadly disappear forever.
SIERRA: Just this summer an auction
house sale of two Nigerian artifacts
led to a public outcry after an
article claimed the sculptures
were likely stolen from Nigeria in
the late 1960s during its civil war.
And it isn’t just the auction houses or museums
that are guilty of these sales and acquisitions.
Take the crafts store Hobby Lobby, which was
forced to forfeit more than 5,500 ancient
tablets and seals after it was found that they
were illegally smuggled artifacts from Iraq.
These crimes, unfortunately, are common,
and often go undetected or unresolved.
SIERRA: So what international laws are there
when it comes to cultural heritage and war?
DAVIS: The legal framework for this really
only developed in recent decades. The main
international law is a treaty from
1970, the 1970 UNESCO Convention,
but also, national law plays a very strong role.
SIERRA: This 1970 convention was created by
the United Nations Educational, Scientific and
Cultural Organization or UNESCO. At its core,
the agreement sets out to prevent the illicit
trafficking of cultural property of all kinds.
But the designation of cultural property is
left to each individual state, so the rules can
be quite different depending on where you are.
DAVIS: And the laws around this are very
complicated because they vary from country
to country. In the U.S., they vary from
state to state, and because of that,
it's quite a challenge for countries to
recover and get these pieces back. For
every headline you see of a piece going
back to Egypt or to Italy or to Cambodia,
those are by far the exceptions, not the
rule. Even in the United States, which has
some of the more favorable laws to claimants
in the world, it's quite the uphill battle.
SIERRA: When you were telling the story, and you
were like, yeah, and then the piece appeared on
the cover of, you know, a very prominent
art house, you know, auction house, like,
isn't that the moment where you were like, the
jig is up, we found it. How does that work?
DAVIS: You would think right? And if only
it were that easy, but unfortunately,
the way these trials are done, the way
these cases are done in the United States,
and there's a similar framework in place in
the United Kingdom, is they're prosecuted under
stolen property laws. The law that's used here
in the U.S., the National Stolen Property Act,
it has nothing to do with cultural heritage.
So lawyers have been very creative in applying
these laws, but to use the example of the piece
from Cambodia, and this is true for for most of
these cases that are done in the U.S. and both
the UK, the government had to show that first,
there was a law in place in Cambodia that
claimed ownership of the statue. Second,
they had to show that the statue was from
Cambodia's current borders. And third,
you also have to show that the piece was removed
after the law went into place. And when a looter
is the first person to see a statue coming out of
the ground, it's rather hard to show from which
side it was taken and when. And you walk through
many museums, and you do have to ask yourself,
how did these pieces get here? In many cases
it's not behavior that we would condone today.
SIERRA: What about the targeting of cultural
heritage during wartime? Do those rules,
sort of, intersect with these other issues?
DAVIS: As I mentioned, you know, plunder and
destruction, they often go hand in hand. And
the connection between cultural destruction
and genocide is a very clear one. In fact,
the man who was the mastermind behind the Genocide
Convention had actually felt very strongly that
cultural destruction be included as a definition
requirement of genocide. And if you think about
it, that makes sense. I mean, if you're going to
destroy a people, you have to destroy everything
that made them great too. You don't want these
reminders of wonderful things that they did.
And likewise, if you're willing to destroy
everything that's sacred to a people, the next
step is to destroy the people themselves. There's
a very, very dark connection there. And again,
we see this with the Nazis, we see this with the
Khmer Rouge in Cambodia who targeted Cham mosques,
Catholic churches, and contemporary Buddhist
temples. And it's something we have definitely
seen particularly by Daesh, by ISIS, throughout
the Middle East and North Africa today.
SIERRA: The history of these injustices is long
- but people do push back. It’s a tough job,
and it often falls to individuals and local
activists, many of whom risk their lives
to protect cultural heritage. One of those
people is Amr, who in 2014 helped organize
support for activists to protect mosaics
in the war-torn city of Ma`arat, Syria.
AL-AZM: The museum in Ma`arat contains
the largest and most important collection
of mosaics from the UNESCO designated world
heritage sites of the Dead Cities, so there's
a unique and extremely important collection of
mosaics stored and displayed in that Museum,
and it was totally exposed. We use very simple
techniques such as just literally covering the
walls of the mosaics with cloth and then
putting sandbags against it. This proved
to be an extremely effective way to protect
the museum because a few months after that,
the museum was hit by a Syrian regime airstrike.
It caused extensive damage to the courtyard,
but the mosaics inside the museum were protected
from the blast because of the sandbags we had put
on it. This museum has since been hit two more
times as well. And in every time that the museum
was hit the contents were always protected.
And we've done that in other museums as well.
The other thing we do, we also do, is we send
out site monitors. These are local volunteers,
local activists again who go out and essentially
try to document looting activities and, you know,
any damage or destruction that might occur to
a cultural heritage site, you know, we have
teams out in Idlib that go out on a regular
basis and putting their lives in danger here.
SIERRA: What can a vulnerable
country do to make itself more
resilient to looting? And what
can the rest of the world do?
DAVIS: Criminologists will tell you that
no illicit trade in history has ever been
defeated at its source. It just doesn't happen,
it is a problem of demand. And right now,
the United States is the largest art market
in the world we’re the source of that demand,
both licit and illicit. So really, it takes
action by countries like the United States,
places like Europe, to stop that demand, these
sites were intact, in some cases for millennia,
until there was a market for the material in them,
and then they were destroyed in a matter of years.
SIERRA: So spreading the word about how
these things are stolen and laundered, helps.
DAVIS: It helps. In fact, I think it's the most
important thing that can be done. It is hugely
important that buyers beware. And there certainly
is a legitimate market. But the art market,
you know, it's a market that's very easy for
criminals to take advantage of, because of the
lack of regulation because of this long standing
culture of secrecy. And so it really is on buyers,
on the sellers, to do their homework to
do the so called due diligence and to make
sure that what they're purchasing is not the
product of crime or conflict or terrorism.
SIERRA: It's hard listening to you because I
love museums and it's really unsettling to me
to feel like objects I've looked at a museum
or sought out in other countries at museums,
I mean, they just have so much blood
and crime in their history. But,
how do you know which museum is the
right one, where it's supposed to be?
DAVIS: I do think museums have come a long
way in recent years. When reports started
emerging of the looting and trafficking that
was happening in ISIS occupied territory,
museums were sounding the alarm to help fight back
against that illicit trade. It's a very different
reaction than we saw during the Cambodian Civil
War when, you know, I've talked to curators who
were at some quite prominent museums at the
time who said Cambodian pieces were coming in
in the 1970s with dirt and leaves still stuck on
them. So, things have come a long way. That said,
we do still see museums, including those here
in the United States, you know, getting caught
with pieces that were looted, in some cases
recently looted. One prominent Museum in New
York recently had to return a gold sarcophagus
to Egypt that was looted during the Revolution.
This isn't a piece that came out decades ago.
So this is still very much a problem. That
said, again, museums can really be a
force for good in this if they want to.
SIERRA: The question inevitably becomes,
where do artifacts belong? Somewhere safe
from a conflict zone far away? Somewhere where
everyone can see it? Or do they belong at home,
to the culture and country that they come from?
DAVIS: Cultural heritage is a key part of
identity. This is the cultural property,
to use the legal term, of these communities of
these countries. And those who remove it, they're
thieves, pure and simple. And unfortunately,
in many cases, they're also war profiteers.
And so, yes, I do think that it's up
to the country to decide what happens
to its cultural heritage. That said, they're
understandably quite proud of their cultural
heritage. They want people to see their
antiquities in museums around the world.
They just want it to be in a responsible way,
and there are ways to achieve that. You know,
why do Western museums need to own these? The
focus shouldn't be on ownership. The focus should
be on working with countries around the world
to secure loans, so these pieces can be seen in
a responsible way. And that is something
we're seeing starting to happen as well.
SIERRA: Do you feel that the coverage of
these kinds of lootings or destruction
isn't as obvious to people because when we
talk about war, we focus on lost lives. And
that sometimes talking about, you know,
a piece at a museum could almost seem,
not frivolous, but you know, not
have as much weight to people?
AL-AZM: You know, we do face a binary,
especially, where you have horrific conflicts,
ongoing conflicts, and me being a Syrian,
I've been asked before, in the face of such
a terrible humanitarian catastrophe, why are
you so worried? Why are you focused on cultural
heritage? I reject this binary. I think you can do
both. And I would go a step further and say this,
a conflict like Syria has to end one day. And
when it does, Syrians are going to have to
get together. And they're going to have to try to
find what common denominators exist between them,
what makes a Syrian a Syrian. Syrian society, as a
result of this conflict, has ruptured across every
possible cleavage, you know, social, sectarian,
economic, religious. What bridges are left,
that they can communicate across? And I think
this is where shared common history, this is
where their cultural heritage can play a vital
role in that. It could be a connecting point,
it could be something that brings people
together. And if you think of the museums
and the cultural heritage sites, these could
become safe spaces, a space where Syrians,
can come together, meet in an environment
where it doesn't matter who you were,
what side you fought on, it connects you to
the other side. So, I see cultural heritage
and the preservation of cultural heritage,
not just as saving Syria’s past in this case,
but it's also a key to its future too. Without
that past shared heritage, there is going to
be no future Syria, because it's the only
thing left that holds the society together.
SIERRA:
Want to learn more about art and
cultural heritage in conflict?
Head to CFR.org/WhyItMatters for
the show notes from this episode.
Interested in saying hi to the
Why It Matters team? You can
always reach out on email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
If you like the show, subscribe! We are
on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher, or
any platform where you can get your audio. And if
you like what you hear, please leave us a review.
Why It Matters is a production of the
Council on Foreign Relations. The show
is created and produced by Jeremy Sherlick,
Asher Ross, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our
sound designer is Markus Zakaria, and he also
composed the track you are hearing right now.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and Doug
Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer. Extra help
with this episode was provided by the amazing
Teagan Judd. This was also the final episode
with our summer intern Wynne Dieffenbach, who
did some incredible work and who will be missed.
Original music is composed
by Ceiri Torjussen. Special
thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle
Sierra, signing off. See you soon!